our next speaker is elizabeth lee
trained as an archaeologist she is the
vice president of SARC an international
nonprofit organization based in Oakland
California whose mission is to digitally
capture archive and make accessible the
World Heritage Sites Elizabeth okay
thank you for the invitation Stephan and
it's an honor to be here there's been
some wonderful presentations this
morning I'm going to be speaking in
particular about a joint initiative
between sci-arc icomos and Yale's
Institute for preservation of cultural
heritage we called it project Anka for
the Arabic word for the Phoenix and the
premises that while there's been recent
destruction and catastrophic destruction
in some cases it represents a fraction
of the total sites in the area that can
be effective affected and that
physically safeguarding some of these
sites can be very problematic but it is
possible to proactively document the
sites and have that record available for
the future so as I mentioned it's a
partnership between the International
Council on monuments and sites and in
particular we heard from samir abdullah
whose chair of the working group for
safeguarding syria and iraq cultural
heritage they've been instrumental in
identifying partners and ways to move
forward on the ground and Yale has come
on board as well as a partner in the
project to help in the dissemination and
scholarly annotation of the data
collected some of you may not know that
much about cyrix so I will give a brief
introduction on on sy arc we're a
non-profit or NGO organization with our
headquarters in the San Francisco Bay
Area we've we were a pioneer in the use
of 3d scanning for cultural heritage and
have been doing so since about two
thousand three we have over 200 sites
cultural heritage sites in our archive
and we work very closely with the
ministries of culture state boards of
Antiquities on the ground to perform
this work
perhaps the best example of why we exist
is from a project in the kasubi tombs in
Uganda this was back in about two
thousand nine we threw a crew captured
the monument and this is the laser scan
data so the Machine sends out these
pulsed beams of light and captures data
points every couple of millimeters on
the structure and what that does is it
allows us to visualize the site like
this but that record is an archived for
the future it's made available to the
public for interpretation but it can
also be used to extract blueprints of
the monument so when just a year after
the work the 3d scanning work had been
performed the site was the victim of
arson and so you know very quickly
within the days following the fire we
were contacted we sent these blueprints
to the site and they were able to begin
reconstruction so the data within our
archive is more than just sort of a
pretty picture it's able to help inform
these restoration efforts and that's why
we got involved in this how we can
proactively documents in these sites so
we use a suite of technology so
everything from the scanner that I
mentioned we use drones to document the
sites and then we also use a close range
scanning to get highly detailed
information of things like mosaics and
frescoes so when we started this project
anka it was all about how we can get
into the the most urgent areas and
earlier this year we were able to take a
substantial step forward with an initial
training of the directorate general of
Integrity's and museums five of their
staff members traveled to beirut we did
two train two days of training at the
unesco offices there unesco is wonderful
in providing space and also doing a lot
of the coordination and then we were
able to do a practical hands-on training
at the ciroc Museum in Beirut so these
these these are employees of the djm
came and over
course of three days were able to master
the technology and the tech went back
with them into Damascus so we did
classroom exercises and we also did the
practical experience and they're now
back the djm has selected a list of
priority monuments working with the eco
most working group this is the first
site that they're working on in Damascus
so this is back in Syria they're doing
this work and then sending back the data
for review so in this case we're we're
getting this building this on the ground
inventory of the structures and we will
have this data for use in any kind of
reconstruction or rehabilitation and
we'll also be able to use it beyond that
in terms of what sex there's a lot more
to do in Syria there are a lot of
discussions now in terms of what will
happen with a site like Paul Mira
especially reconstruction efforts so
there's a lot of work that can be done
in doing this documentation before any
efforts on the ground take place so we
know exactly what exists today and so
we're looking forward to doing that in
collaboration with the djm and then we
want to expand to other countries
project on codes envisioned as this
emergency documentation of at-risk areas
so moving beyond just Syria and Iraq
into other places that are susceptible
but are still accessible is a big urgent
need so we welcome any kind of
collaboration and we also will be
sharing the materials the last point I
will leave in terms of what's next you
know the practical applications for
heritage conservation and management are
really well understood with this data
the thing that's kind of coming next is
really being able to use this digital
data to connect people to these places
and and so this is from an example of a
museum that we work with in Austria
called the ars electronica they're doing
life-sized 3d projections of sites
within our archive as a way to connect
people to these places that you know can
seem really far-flung that this data can
make it real can keep these sites
relevance and
the stories and the end the people
connected so thank you